I had to take an antibiotic a few weeks ago for the infection and totally messed with my gut.
I've taken a clear digest.
The clear digest is not going to fix the damage that the antibiotic did, but the clear digest will help you.
Replace the HCl in your stomach to make sure you're digesting your food real well and to give you digesting enzymes to help you with digestion of your food.
And it doesn't help much, so that's why it's not helping much.
Like chemo, do you suggest that I take a probiotic?
Yes, she's right.
What is your opinion of me taking a course of probiotics?
Um, if they were all, how long should I take it?
Well, you can take probiotics every day and, and, you know, continuously.
I don't think they're necessary to take every day continuously, but definitely you need to take a probiotic.
But if there's numerous studies in a cable, if you have to take it antibiotic and you take a probiotic, it wasn't even specific to any type of probiotic.
They actually studied all these different specific probiotics and all of them work the exact same way in the fact that they help prevent damage to the gut.
So just get a probiotic.
We have a pride probiotic that I'm really excited about because it's a certain strain that will also help the brain.
And that can be really good to prevent any infection of the brain, plus it can be really good to help with chemo.
So, um, probiotic is the new one in the store that's our pride that they want to go on.
Um, and I would just take it on, you know, you tell you feel like your gut's better than maybe take it for another week and then start taking it away a couple of times a week.